people make a purchasing decision based
on their prediction that they will get
value and access of the cost of the
purchase for example when I would sell
weight loss I would say like well what
did you do so far and they would usually
say some sort of Fitness thing some sort
of nutrition thing whatever and I would
say well it sounds like you've never had
Fitness Nutrition and accountability
together you've had one or two of the
three but not all three together and
that for most people was an epiphany
where they're like you're right I've
only done just a diet thing or I've only
done just a workout thing and so that
was value and then they were like wow
that's a new perspective a new paradigm
now I believe and I will predict if I
continue to work with this person I'll
continue to get more value